ما الذي يجب أن يتوقعه الغرب أن يرى بوتين
يفعله بعد
ذلك ، لذا أعتقد أن ما سيفعله هو
أنه سيضاعف بعض الشيء إلى حد ما بشأن
أنواع الأشياء التي يفعلها
الآن ، سترى المزيد من الهجمات على
البنية التحتية المدنية للأسف
أه ستفعل  انظر أيضًا إلى اختبار ربما لتحريك
القوات الروسية للأمام قليلاً في
مناطق أه من دونج بوس في الجزء الشرقي
من البلاد التي فقد الروس
السيطرة عليها أو لم
يسيطروا عليها بالكامل
حتى هذه النقطة لكن الأوكرانيين
لديهم الكثير من الزخم من جانبهم ،
ولديهم أيضًا القدرة على استخدام
سلسلة التوريد اللوجستية الخاصة بهم بشكل أفضل بكثير مما
يفعله الروس ، لذلك سيواجه
الروس بعض الصعوبات الكبيرة في
محاولة الوصول إلى أهدافهم الحربية ،
لكن بوتين سيحاول
الاستفادة من ذلك.  العديد من الأشياء المختلفة التي
يمكنه من أجلها على الأقل
الوصول إلى طريق مسدود في هذه الحرب ،
آمل ألا يكون قادرًا على القيام بذلك ، لكن
هذا هدف محدد هل يمكن أن يكون هذا العام
هو العام  فشل الهجوم وتنسحب روسيا
بعيدًا ، أعني أنه يمكن لبوتين أن يحافظ على هذا
على المدى الطويل.
القوات الروسية
جاهزة أه حقيقة أنه اضطر إلى
تجنيد 300 ألف أه جديد
بشكل أساسي في الجيش الروسي على
أساس طارئ يدل على أن هناك
قدرًا كبيرًا من الضعف في
الجيش الروسي الحالي وستستمر نقاط الضعف هذه
وستزداد سوءًا بسبب
أنواع الأشياء التي يقوم بها
الآن أه إذن ما
يحاول بوتين فعله أه هو إلقاء نظرة جيدة حقًا
على كل شيء ، لكن قدرته على
إجراء عمليات هجومية
ستختبر بشدة وأعتقد
أنها ستفشل